hi my name is Nora Jones and I feel
ecstatic about being Conan O'Brien's
friend wow ecstatically yeah I do that's
that's fun you know I've adored you for
so many years and you were uh kind
enough to come on my late night show uh
or in shows plural I'll say over the
years oh well I was trying to figure out
how many times you know what we could
probably look it up but we came on it's
okay everybody get going nine people in
the room started getting on their
computers oh no I'm just got some
medical results
yeah you started crying
um don't worry six months is a long time
uh
um oh Jesus oh my God too long in this
job yeah okay take it easy we're sitting
here sorry I'm not gonna waste time
bantering with you about your life
expectancy
um you came on many times and in so many
different guys is because you would
perform uh yourself uh you'd be
performing your work and then I remember
we did a George week once in honor of
George Harrison and you know Paul Simon
came all these amazing people came by
for the week uh Danny Harrison was
around uh and it was this wonderful week
and you came and I'm trying to think I
did behind that locked oh behind that
locked door okay it was so fun that was
one of our actually I remember my band
and I because we'd done a lot of TV
shows together at that point that was
probably one of our best TV performances
you know usually you do it and you're
like ah it would have been better if
this and we're like yes nailed it yeah
the problem is you did that on camera
you turned to the camera
nailed it
you know when you started dancing and
saying better than Harrison yeah that's
right that put a lot of people off uh no
you were uh yeah I was trying to
remember what song it was this morning
and I could have just typed in
you because we live in that world where
I can type in uh you know Nora Jones
George Harrison Conan or whatever and it
would come up immediately but uh I can't
work my own phone I can't turn it on
that's less fun in any way yeah exactly
so uh but you
um you came on that week and you were
always coming by and Performing and
I just loved it every time you came on
the show thanks a massive fan and so I'm
a massive fan I remember the first time
I came on your show was for my first
record 2000 2002 yeah right and I was so
excited oh well that's I remembered you
uh of course that was the record Come
Away With Me Five Grammys
you know I remembered at that time
out about you hearing about you and
saying this who is this Nori Jones what
is this I'm very skeptical what is this
Come Away With Me album I better check
it out and see if it's up to Snuff and
listening to it and thinking I don't
understand how someone your age at the
time or anybody could come out with an
album of all brand new standards it was
like this is all these are all gonna be
in standards books that everyone has to
have forever and I was like everyone
else in the world like a 85 billion
other people completely floored well
that's nice to say uh yeah and I
remember whoever was playing guitar with
you
I think you did
um don't know why and I was he offered
to show me how to play it on the guitar
afterwards really so he came into I
don't know who it was but he came into
my dressing room and he's showing me how
to play the guitar parts and uh I was
like I think I got it and then we got
into a lot of stuff you know edits and
work and we got to figure out tomorrow's
show and then I got home completely
forgot I think it's a hard song to play
on guitar yeah it's probably not in my
wheelhouse it's not in my wheelhouse it
was either Jesse Harris who wrote the
song or Adam Levy who toured with me at
the time but that's yeah that's really
fun
um I think it was the person who wrote
the song then it was Jesse Harris yeah
well Jesse I need and I need you to come
back
it's uh I need another lesson he'll
probably send you a video if you just
give me give me no I need him in person
he needs to fly out to LA at his own
expense that I do require I wanted to
mention first that you have your own
podcast which I've really been enjoying
thanks it's Nora Jones is playing along
is playing along and what's nice
about it is that you get these people
it's two musicians talking and screwing
around and it's a very loose atmosphere
and I was listening to you with Jeff
Tweedy who's one of my favorite humans
yeah mine too and um it was such a great
Vibe and I was thinking man am I to be
on this podcast and then I realized oh
right I'm not a musician except you are
well not really but can you does it ever
expand out to non-musicians if they're
playing music with me I think my only my
way in is you know there's so many
podcasts of course and you guys were
kind of a big inspiration because over
the pandemic I I just hearing you guys
laugh really lit me up and that's nice
because it's like belly laughs were
needed and um it felt really good and um
I you screwing around with people on
this podcast is kind of like what I want
to do except I'm a musician so it's a
little bit different no but it's the
same idea there's such a we talk about
this a lot on this but I've been
fascinated all my life with the fact
that I have a
um natural uh you know bent towards
comedy but I'm always The Grass Is
Always Greener I'm always peering over
into the music yard I see that and
thinking man that's so cool that's the
cool place to be I'm over here with the
Laughing clowns
well sorry not you guys oh oh no no no I
never don't think of you as comedians at
all oh
you guys are hilarious I mean what do I
know I'm just a musician thank you yes
yes you don't have a professional eye
like I do understand
clown but like hearing you with Kevin
Nealon just like messing around I mean
that makes me so happy and I feel like
that's kind of what I'm trying to do
with music with with people who I know
some who I don't know and we find this
commonplace and we're speaking like the
same language well this is what always
fascinates me because I you know but you
if there's something that you don't do
you put it on a pedestal or you don't
have a natural inclination so when I sit
you when I see you sit down in the piano
and play and sing I think well she's
superhuman I am Immortal you know uh I
said amortal not Immortal
I just want to be really clear
um but uh but I there is such a close
connection between comedy and music yeah
we there's jamming riffing whatever we
call it riffing I guess you guys Jam who
knows what everyone calls it but when
you sit down and you you communicate
with each other yeah and you're doing it
musically and I do think there's a
musical element to when
if I'm with Kevin Nealon or any of these
you know hilarious people
sometimes I forget what we're even doing
but we're all laughing and I can't even
tell you afterwards how we got there and
I think maybe that's what it's like in
music it's the same I mean you you could
do a perfect take of a song and it just
doesn't feel right or you can do a
really messed up messy version of a song
together and it just feels magical and
it hits the spot you know